what if you are the little man so I got
a great question from one of my loyal
YouTube viewers game ovah who wrote in
the say what if you are your own worst
little man and this is a fantastic
question and when I talk about the
little man it's usually talking about
somebody else you know the other people
in your life who hate on your idea to
tell you why it's not gonna work out
point out all the flaws in your plan but
often the little men can be yourself
right where you hate on yourself and you
tell yourself all the reasons why
something's not going to work and so how
do you overcome it so I give three
strategies to help you
number one is remember why why are you
doing this what is your main reason for
launching this company or for trying to
hit this big goal that you're going for
why is it important to you right is it
to build a better life for yourself or a
better life your family or to help
people whatever it is you need to have a
strong why right I want to help a
billion entrepreneurs that's a huge
number that that motivates me that
excites me and thinking about that helps
me overcome things that I might be
afraid of you know I might be afraid of
getting on the camera doing my first
video I might be afraid of doing a TV
interview I might be afraid of of
launching a new product whatever it is I
might be afraid but helping remember
that big why keeps me excited and
motivated so what is your big why then
if you don't have one then you're not
gonna have success in business right you
have to have a strong wife if you're
doing this just to make money it's not
going to work that's me something else
is driving you forward and so whenever
you're facing that self-criticism and
thinking I can never do this think about
that big why and what you're trying to
accomplish to give you some extra
motivation and courage to overcome
number two surround yourself with
greatness when you are down on yourself
it's important to have people and an
environment that supports you that makes
you feel great that makes you feel
invincible that makes you feel like you
can accomplish anything
so maybe it's a friend who believes in
you or a family member who says you can
do it or
in videos maybe my channel helps you or
some other channels for me it was
reading stories of famous entrepreneurs
and how they got started and had nothing
and and built themselves up when people
didn't believe in them but they believe
in themselves and and reading those
stories make me feel like if she can do
it if he can do it and I can do it too
and that gave me the courage to keep
going and to break out of my zone that
you sometimes get into where you feel
like like it's not gonna happen for you
so we didn't those stories helped me but
you want to surround yourself with
greatness whatever you can do to help
you stay inspired if it's listening to
music or watching interviews or reading
books whatever it is surround yourself
with greatness and number three is take
small steps a lot of times the
self-doubt comes in because you're here
and you want to go here and that looks
like too big a gap and you don't have
the skills or experience to get there
and so you criticize yourself you become
the little man you say I can never get
there but what you want to do is break
that down so that jump isn't as big so
you only have to go here and then you go
here and here and here and here and if
you've gone from here to here then
taking that step isn't that scary right
you say well I can't get here there's no
way I'm gonna get here but I can get
here I think I can get here so you can
do it and when you do it then you
realize hey you know what I can do that
again and I can go here now and I can go
here and I can go here so you're not
being your own worst enemy as much
because you're taking smaller steps but
still hitting that big goal so whatever
it is that you know you may get you may
say I could never be on CNN as an expert
whatever you're doing I can never be on
scene as an expert that's that's way too
complicated that's way too big I'm not
that good but you could start small you
could start by making a YouTube video
right one YouTube video and then you can
make another one and then maybe you can
do a presentation and then when you make
another one and you keep taking your
small steps up and when you look back
and say wow I actually did a lot but
it's just the accumulation of small
steps that help you towards your big
goal so remember how to stop being your
own worst little man number one remember
why you're doing this number two
surround yourself with greatness and
number three take small steps believe
for those of you watching you like the
video you can support me by clicking on
the link in the description you can
leave a comment let me know what you
think and click on my face subscribe to
the channel thank you so much I'll see
you soon